welcome to council geeks my name is
Nathaniel Wayne and I enjoyed by Paula
Vito and Ryan Davey we have all seen
Batman V Superman we're going to talk a
little bit about the movie and a lot
about what happens next
Paul I believe you're gonna have the
differing opinion because mine was some
good parts but it's a mess of a film
Ryan's was hey that yeah so Paul I'm
gonna actually yield the floor for a
little bit and let you give your
thoughts on the movie and then we'll
we'll be you damos in the theater and I
was trying to set myself up for his
negative uh viewing experience as I
possibly could while I was watching the
film I kept waiting to hate it and I
didn't oh yeah yeah I should mention
spoilers for this thing it's been out
long enough we're just gonna talk about
himself you're talking about a spoiler
or where Bruce Wayne's mama's shop I
know I hadn't warned people before we
got there oh right and the boat sinks in
the end this is Frank Miller's Batman or
that the audience need to accept that
this is not the Batman and Superman that
we know and love from the regular comics
this is how Frank Miller would write
these characters so you're accepting the
movie on its own terms
yes okay we need to go to what my end
please feel free to view my utter hatred
of Superman Returns Superman what is it
minnow steel the reason I hated that
movie
mm-hm was I would argue that Superman
does not show off in that film mm-hmm
I would argue that Superman does show up
in this movie where so when this movie
in this movie we get to see him doing
some things that I need Superman to him
he is working for the Daily Bugle as
Clark plant a planet they say bugle yeah
yeah okay can we fix that in post
no he's in love with Lois Lane how do
those things happen I don't care right
and so I am I am happy to see him in
those roles we also see him in many
scenes I would argue acting heroically
and selflessly I would argue that I saw
in a lot
waise Superman being super can I just
didn't get jacked yep
I saw Superman go through the motions of
being Superman with no soul of Superman
anywhere because if I look at Man of
Steel and I look at his conversation
sitting down with Lois explaining that
the S is his family crest and that it
means hope and that I saw the soul of
Superman in that scene in Man of Steel I
did not see a lot of the behavior of
Superman in that movie but I saw the
soul of Superman in that scene in this
movie I saw the actions of Superman and
not the soul but movie were talking
about I should back up a little bit and
say that I don't recommend this movie to
any one of the three of us the one who's
defending the moon yes still won't
recommend it that should tell you
everything you need to know well she
sure was Nathaniel your analogy that you
told me so go your based on your
expectations and what you got so it's
kind of like having a giant monster
behind you and you're sort of backing up
and you're really afraid it's about to
bite you on the back of the neck of the
head but instead it nuzzles you a little
still a monster and it's still awful
right but but it didn't maul you to
death
it really should look at it directly but
I dress so here's the puzzle that
Affleck is the nuzzle happens and ashtag
Ben Affleck is the nazil ultimately my
problem of this movie is it is just
objectively badly made it is a poorly
assembled film I lost count of how many
times we jump into the middle of a scene
with no establishing shot sorry I don't
know where we are when we are why we are
here
so maybe the three-hour cut will make it
flow better but at this point I don't
care
I'm too pissed I predetermined I would
hate this movie two years ago but I
expected to hate it because of the way
it showed Batman and Superman the movie
surprised me in that what I hated about
the movie were the things that Nathaniel
was talking about the movie was bad it
was badly made the script was a mess the
editing was all over the place the
decisions and the characters didn't make
sense I actually love these characters a
group of these characters I think most
of us did write and and so I am grasping
at any kind of straw I can coming off of
this and actually even partly because of
this I am excited for a Wonder Woman
movie I know you don't want to see the
Batman movie or I am but I am excited to
see I'm this Batman get a solo movie and
I'm still excited for Suicide Squad I'm
intrigued by cyborg but my excitement
for the other things I do not feel the
need to defend this movie to justify my
excitement for the rest of this universe
Warner Brothers originally announced 10
movies from their DC Comics universe
slate between 2016 and 2020 basically
two a year for the next five years when
this thing was met with a critical just
hatred and vitriol a lot of people think
okay oh they didn't respond well it did
it had a pretty good opening weekend I
had a really good opening weekend I was
like it's a record-breaking opening
weekend it came out in March
yeah these don't make a Records in March
so it didn't have a competition but it
has plummeted and this movie might not
make a billion dollars
yeah is a big deal and when you factor
in all of the costs and the margins it
if Warner Brothers makes profit from
this it's gonna be a narrow margin and
they've got it they've got to recognize
that now what it appears that they're
doing is they're not backing off their
Cinematic Universe they've actually
announced two more movies at some point
in the next couple years and I said what
those movies are but they're doubling
down their DC Comics universe on their
lego franchise and on the Harry Potter
spin-off magical beasts and where to
find them yeah yeah and what they're
going to do is they're smaller
independent projects that made Warner
Brothers a name and made them an awards
caliber while
our commodity those movies are gonna get
dropped in fact there was already a new
story today of like a pretty high
caliber like I expected movie got
dropped by Warner Brothers and Netflix
has picked it up so Warner Brothers
wants to be in Disney's game which is
make a buttload of money yeah so and so
they don't know that they need to spend
four hundred million on the next one
either well I mean I don't think they're
gonna have the next one is justice Lee
will see it end and that's and that's
the thing so from here we're gonna talk
about mostly that and what comes next
and what's the impact of this thing now
Justice League is the media thing and
pretty much anything else you can hinge
your hope on well it's a different
creative team Justice League is not I
think Warner Brothers initially blew off
the critical response when they saw the
opening weekend numbers then the second
weekend took a nosedive and it was a big
drop and they had no competition in the
second weekend it would have been one
thing if there was if if like Batman vs
Superman had come out the weekend before
Civil War and then Civil War cut into it
the second weekend that would justify
that drop nothing like that came out in
the second weekend and still had a huge
drop yep so when they saw that I think
they are panicking slightly the things
start shooting in a week they're not
gonna pull the director but and Ryan and
I had started talking about this before
they have done something because I have
no doubt that at this point as you said
Warner Brothers is doubling down on this
universe right so then they still are
banking a lot on this series of films I
think if they have any doubts about
anything it's Zack Snyder specifically
right now right but they're stuck with
him for Justice League now more recently
I don't know when he became he came on
board but fairly recently added to the
crew of Justice League is George Miller
as a producer so wonder who directed
ranked in Mad Max fury road and was
supposed to direct Justice League about
a decade ago mm-hmm he is now attached
as a producer and my suspicion is is
that he is going to exert a certain
amount of creative leverage and he's
basically going to be asked to kind of
guide Zack Snyder so Zack Snyder's not
just doing his Zack Snyder thing well
even and even men of steel I would argue
you felt a little bit more of
christopher nolan's yes yeah oh man not
a lot man but Christopher Nolan wasn't
involved in Batman V Superman this was
all Snyder so I have a feeling that
George Miller may be a little bit like
say when Spielberg was producing stuff
in the 80s and even though he wasn't
directing you still felt his hand and I
think Warner Brothers is counting on
George Miller to kind of buoy Justice
League a little bit in that fashion they
think Suicide Squad has some potential
to do really really well like really
well is going to be a lighter funnier
film in contrast to this movie I think
marginally I I think it will be more fun
if you'd still be dark but it'll still
be dark but it has color in it most of
the production was done while Batman vs
Superman was being playing I think
Warner Brothers has this kind of
collective vision that is a dark vision
even Wonder Woman which is the third
movie coming out in this late it's a
period piece and all the footage looks
like it's almost sepia gray tone I also
think it's a silent film yeah here's a
question for you
now that Superman's dead spoiler do you
think that they will have him
resurrected at the beginning of Justice
League at the end of Justice League or
will they just let him stay dead they're
not gonna stay dead well I I know he
would come back eventually do you think
he will come back for Justice League or
will they wait and pull him for
something else no he'll be back for
justice so Justice League is a true
partner yeah so are you when you say
justice oh do you mean the first part
I'm losing I was gonna say if you think
he's coming back watch half do you think
he's coming in so like do you think like
the first movie will be like a search
for Spock for my money first movie is
just assemble the league oh crap it's
not enough and then Superman shows up at
the very end of the first half
based on what Warner Brothers and what
Zack Snyder has appeared to be doing
which is just taking whatever has been
popular and whatever has sold well there
is a growing concern or a speculation
that looking at Batman's weird
of the future where there's the Omega
symbols of Darkseid and there's a pair
of demons flying around and Superman is
some sort of psycho killer with his own
little army
if that is true a lot of people suspect
that Darkseid will resurrect Superman as
his own agent and we will get sort of a
Batman Superman war like in the video
game and comic series injustice gods
among us I hate that idea and I'm like
99% sure it will happen because yeah
that's that's the state that these
movies have left Ben maybe they'll get
josh trank to do the sequel so thoughts
on the flash Aquaman cyborg
Aquaman did not get me excited for
Aquaman movie he looks kind of dumb I
here's the thing I thought he actually
looked cool but he literally did nothing
like I saw him floating in the water
aye aye aye nice practically said out
loud you gonna do something
are you just you're not no you're not
gonna do anything okay I thought he was
like the guy cleaning the tank and like
Vedas caught him like on camera then
he's like I actually didn't even see the
flash one I think I even linked in you
missed yeah yeah so yeah yeah it hipster
flash I did not like either of those the
cyborg one surprised me I was actually
impressed but like I felt like it's a
long time we're spending watching this
guy scream on the table
the guy who created the Terminator
creating another one of meta casting
actually kind of like it was actually
okay and I kind of completely forgot
about it but I was like you know I would
actually like to see something done with
cyborg in this unit and if they do it as
a Frankenstein story then there's this
might kind of be a cool thing but it was
just like that's a WoW he's screaming a
lot like how much time are we spending
on this whole sequence and like I really
hope the next thing she opens up is like
a video of like the panda sneezing that
would kind of bring this back together
I think the cyborgs one is the one they
put the most effort into I think as they
knew they had to because nobody right
aside from actual comic book readers
knows who cyborg is right right I I will
say none of them made me excited for
those future movies okay I mean the
cyborg one maybe a little bit because I
had no expectations for but I was like
okay I guess this is a real thing
if I separate my cell phone maybe
they'll maybe they'll make an
interesting cyborg movie but Cybermen
has never even been a solo agent he's
always been part of the Teen Titans or
now more recently to Justice League in
the comics yeah like you know he's not
somebody that you he doesn't have a solo
story he doesn't have an origin story he
doesn't have another think they have a
rogue's gallery known and actually his
origin story is what we saw in that I
want to see a good Wonder Woman movie so
I will see that I want to see a good
Aquaman movie so I will hold my breath
I'm intended and go to the theater to
see that Aquaman movie but I don't know
that I will see an Aquaman movie in that
one I think I'll see Namor the
Submariner yeah is the fact that Batman
at the very least he made a conscious
decision
I will kill Superman mm-hmm so does that
create a problem with the fact that he
hasn't killed the Joker no well I was
gonna try and argue against it but yeah
I was too yeah is it just a numbers game
are we rationalizing that the Joker
could kill a thousand people sure and
Superman could kill a billion right I
mean I guess the question is when they
get to the Batman solo movie are they
better off trying to answer that or are
they better off ignoring that question
altogether and just being like please
just accept this movie on its own terms
let's not talk about a man or was that
question I will say for the first time
in a movie and I'm talking about the
Nolan films here I did actually see
Batman have a plan before he went in to
fight someone like a real plan that
wasn't just punch guy in the face right
which was my major criticism
you know the Nolan films was Batman just
shut up and beat up people the plan did
devolve into he pulled the bathroom sink
off of the wall and hit him with the
same so there was a plan before that but
I think I'm tapped out it's it is
exhausting to talk about okay I do what
I do want to mention this though like I
do love these characters Superman Batman
and Wonder Woman these are character I
love them more than any Marvel superhero
or villain by a wide margin I do but the
Marvel movies haven't let me down yet
they haven't all been good I will grant
you they haven't all been good but they
haven't disappointed me to the extent
that two DC movies in a row have with
Man of Steel and no I'll go beyond that
Green Lantern Jonah Hex Man of Steel and
now this one right I just I don't want
this anymore
you guys look beaten down so I get I
think well I think we'll wrap up there
so this is your chance to plug who's
plug in much a plug in all right I'll do
it first I've got a number of podcasts
they're all available on the fire and
water podcast network Secret Origins
podcast which is about the secret
origins comics published by DC in the
1980s give me those Star Wars which is
about Star Wars movies memorabilia
pretty much anything check out the
latest episode it's about a teaser
trailer to rogue one a Star Wars story
and power of fishnets which is about the
DC characters as otama and Black Canary
you can also find some of my work at
Rising Sun cop Rising Sun comics calm my
pet ninja I'm the creator and writer of
a webcomic my pet ninja and Paul and I
co-created the webcomic
red and green both are available at
Rising Sun comics calm in addition to
working on red and green with Ryan daily
I am also the lead writer on a book by
residents in comics called armadillo
justice space armadillos fighting space
ants set and the American Midwest it's
the book you didn't know you needed to
read okay then so thanks for joining me
guys I'm
sorry to push the through when I put you
through you oh god you books just really
look awful at this point if you're
watching this video you can see a longer
more or less uncut version of the same
conversation and you can hear that on
the council of geeks podcast on itunes
and stitcher thank you so much for
joining us until next time this council
is adjourned
hashtag Ben Affleck is the muscle let's
make that a thing